we talked about the nine hero sympathy
qualities that's the list this is also
in the book I have put stars there by
five of them because I believe at a
minimum every hero he or he or she needs
to have at least these five qualities
one or two more wouldn't hurt but they
need to have these you this allows your
audience in it allows them to identify
with at least temporarily and they don't
have to be you know just somebody pure
and good we don't much like pure and
good people all that much they're not
very interesting but they have facets
and qualities but one of those qualities
is we have to be able to like them up to
a certain degree and that goes for all
kinds of heroes and there are a number
of different kinds of heroes all heroes
must be at the very least empathetic and
I just put on you know five different
kinds of heroes here the cap some
categories for which this remains true
just to prove the point anti-heroes a
lot of people ask me about that but Eric
Eric this is an antihero that can't be
they can't be sympathetic well they need
to be if it's going to work remember
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo Lisbeth
has anybody seen okay okay starting to
worry there oh yes good good
but Lisbeth is this dark self-contained
she lives in her isolated emotional
bubble because she has been hurt so much
since childhood she is a profoundly
wounded person but she still has six out
of nine of the sympathy characters her
characteristics
um tragic hero Scarface Tony Montana a
formal tragedy
that's king where that's Macbeth that is
a contemporary that's Scarface and these
are otherwise admirable heroes who have
one fatal flaw within them that they
cannot correct
the character growth is not possible for
this person and that becomes the
admonishment tale of we know that they
will be destroyed and they will be dead
by the end of the movie that it kind of
said is kind of sad because we know what
they could have been - if they had had
that one thing fixed within themselves
the tragic hero Tony Montana in Scarface
tragic hero out of the nine sympathy
tools he has eight of them and it works
quite well catalyst hero have any of you
seen an old movie called the in the heat
of the night good a couple anyway it's a
terrific movie if you ever want to spend
a nostalgia night Sidney Poitier plays
Virgil Tibbs actually the part that that
that year I think it was uh that was the
movie in the heat of the night that took
Best Picture
I think he did I think he did right
right right
no no there were there were some before
yeah yeah right right
although I think he won
maybe that came later lilies of the
field I think he did yeah anyway history
he is a highly skilled murder
investigator for the police homicide
detective from New York very
sophisticated very good at what he does
he's in the deep south for some reason
and he ends up in jail he gets arrested
for something of course that he didn't
do all of which is outrageous and he is
very blustery and terrific about you
know and you can see Sidney Poitier
playing it
they call me mr. Tibbs and that became
the movie that followed this one when he
became such a popular character I think
they made two or three more movies with
him
as the lead and then there is the
redneck cracker small-town Deep South
sheriff right and that was played by
Steiger rod stay steiker you have great
character actor and of course you know
he's his cracker as they get and so
naturally you've got this wonderful
personal conflict between these two
people but the one who does the growing
and character growth is the sheriff and
not the the hero not Virgil Tibbs
and that's catalyst hero that there are
those kinds of heroes who do not
personally change but bring about change
in others trickster hero Axel Foley
remember Eddie Murphy in Beverly Hills
Cop remember that's the old series and
he is the trickster Harry hero is is
it's funny energetic and always sticking
it to the man you know to use old terms
and very snide and playful and jester
esque with authority
that's the trickster hero and hasn't
been a number of movies like that of
with that character in them but they too
need to be sympathetic and then the
mentally challenged hero that's a whole
sub-genre - that's not too hard because
before because of their disadvantages
going in they were automatically
sympathetic for them Forrest Gump I am
Sam dumb and Dumberer
those kind of you know the mentally
challenged characters are natural we are
naturally affectionate toward them but
there's other things you can't let it
you know you have to keep it keep it
alive and you have to be careful - they
have to be sympathetic as well all just
to prove that the
sympathy requirements remain the same
and you need to pay attention to it okay
pop quiz
everybody got to take out a piece of
paper no no no sorry rotten joke rotten
joke but I do have a question for you
for the pop quiz take a look at this
list you'll get out of your way take of
this look go look at this seven to these
seven titles of pictures what to think
if you've seen two or three of them has
anybody seen two or three of them okay
okay you guys then what to or through
are two things in all up do all of these
films have in common but anything pop
out at you yes they're I believe they
are all one hero movies yes but what
we're looking for is this yes they all
have despicably unsympathetic heroes and
all of them bombed at the box office
even even Waterworld that cost over 200
million and at the time that was a lot
of money
not anymore but yes these these are your
case examples of when they did not pay
attention to keeping the hero
sympathetic okay just trying to prove
the points